[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 124 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Mok Mandal and I'm here with my
colleague as always
Melanie work hello Melanie how are you
doing today doing okay how are you doing
I'm doing all right I'm still coughing I
think this will probably happen all year
for now exactly
stemming me laughs and everything will
be fine Marc Marc now operates at
coughing level exactly but yeah this
week super excited we have the VP of
infrastructure for Google cloud platform
Eric Brewer joining us today yes it was
fun talking with Eric he has a wide
variety of experiences in background and
that he was one of the key players and
bringing about kubernetes yeah actually
yeah which was super cool it was but
before we get into the interview as
always we have our cool things of the
week and we have a question of the week
and this week's question is if I want to
visualize the network traffic between
pod services within my kubernetes
cluster is there an easy way to do this
there is is there it spoiler alert but
before we talk about that and that'll be
at the end cool things of the week so
you may have heard of next next is the
big cloud event that we have the big
cloud conference that we have on Google
cloud and it is officially July 24
through 26 tickets are now available
we'll have a link you should check it
out and then I know we also have some
satellite cloud next events that are
coming up I guess it's best to say next
or is it cloud next I suspect marketing
I'll get me later anyway so the other
events that are coming up is in London
October 10th and 11th and then also in
Tokyo the 19th and 20th can you register
for those days you can just sign up just
sign up and you'll get updates on when
things are good stuff I'll tell you
what's gonna happen and when
cool nice we also announced that cloud
sequel for Postgres is now generally
available and ready for your production
workloads so pretty short one other than
it's just like generally available which
means you have an SLA now which is
pretty great yes is and apparently while
it was in beta
they added high availability and
replication which was allowing it to
have higher performance instances with
up to 400 16 gigabytes of RAM and they
support 19 additional extensions what's
also really great about
this is that whilst cloud sequel for
Postgres sequel was in beta
they added high availability in
replication and something else that's
really interesting is that they joined
the Google cloud business associates
agreement for hipaa-covered customers
which is a big deal
yes very nice the other cool thing of
the week is that our previous good for
our good friend has gone off into the
world and was doing amazing things
France asked who of course was one of
the original founders of this podcast
was he though I'm not getting between
that anyways they have written this
great blog post because he was working
with trying to call C functions from
bigquery with webassembly and he was
doing this because he wanted to make the
data accessible for others to be able to
explore and they have terabytes of data
and they thought it would be very cool
if their datasets could be made
available for anyone to easily analyze
and so he's got this blog post explains
how he does it and what's fun is that he
connected with one of our colleagues
philippe who is well-versed on the
bigquery space very muchly they wrote up
a blog post as well to explain how to
make it go faster and especially when
you're running C and rust code at scale
ya know he does these really cute tricks
with using wisdom to basically embed C
and then the Philippe also does rust
coat as well to basically make it run on
top of bigquery using its JavaScript
engine it's kind of neat actually I'm
kind of impressed with it that's cool
and anything else Marc is I think I
think you might want to talk about
kubernetes is that right oh yeah I
haven't I haven't spoken about
kubernetes the last 30 seconds so I
should bring that up another fantastic
teammate of ours Sandeep Dinesh has
started this series around kubernetes
best practices kicking it off he's
talking about how and why to build small
container images so he has a blog post
that's up on the Google cloud blog
talking about how to use Alpine to build
small images as well as using multi-step
docker build processes to also help with
that pipeline to go along with that
there's also a series of YouTube videos
as well that you can watch and we'll
link to all that in the show notes
yes and they're also linked at the
bottom of the blog yes all right
well mark I think it's time to go talk
with Eric let's go chat with Eric today
I
I guess the term would possibly be a
little bit giddy I'm sitting in a small
confined room here with Eric Brewer a VP
of infrastructure here at Google Eric
how are you doing today I am doing great
happy to be in a little room happy to be
awesome yeah thanks for coming to join
us I know we want to talk about some
open-source stuffs and distributed
system stuff but before we get stuck
into that can you tell us a little bit
who you are what do you do here at
Google a little bit of your background
sure I am
prior to Google best known as faculty at
UC Berkeley in computer science and out
of that work I founded a company called
Inc to me which did search engines
before Google actually and pioneered a
lot of the modern ways we actually build
what you now call cloud computing so for
example entry was the first company to
use large-scale clusters in the style
that Google does now and pioneered that
as the technology for building large
scale systems and then I've done a bunch
of work in developing countries and then
for the last six years I've been VP at
Google working on this kind of second
revisit of all of the problems of cloud
computing so what does it mean to be VP
of infrastructure it's a good question
because I believe I'm the only VP that
has no direct reports basically you do
whatever you want I am really a kind of
a senior architect for computing for
Google both the cloud part and the
internal part and I kind of view my role
is to help with the kind of the strategy
of Google cloud and also the tactics but
in particular what our technical design
for how we want to build really the next
cloud what we want cloud to be versus
what it's been historically and I
believe congratulations are in order
you just won an award I was yesterday
elected to the American Academy of Arts
and Sciences which is founded by Thomas
Jefferson and others were the inaugural
members in its kind of the I would say
the u.s. is elite association for
scientists and artists and also includes
business people including Larry and
Sergey and several other Googlers and
many people from Berkeley who I know and
I believe you also mentioned before we
started the podcast that Barack Obama is
part of this he is joining this year as
well as a
so and we were also talking about the
fact that you actually met him I have
met him a couple times and he offered
you a job last time I met him was in
October about three years ago when he
did offer me a job and his point was he
kind of had a year and a half to go
maybe a little more and he felt the main
way he could have impact in that time
because Congress was a little bit
divisive was to work on agencies and
have the agencies make progress and he
felt correctly that they needed
technical help and he was recruited to
several people from the Bay Area to do
that I in the end declined in parks I
like what I'm doing at Google but in
part because I have kids it was not a
good time to move to DC but if I could
serve some other time I'd certainly
consider it and I've also worked with
Bill Clinton in the past and so I'm
familiar with the general impact you can
have that way which is great but I
wasn't willing to move this time and
you've helped create usa.gov too that
was the project I did with Bill Clinton
in the year 2000 and that was a the
first federal search engine and covered
all of the US government properties at
that time that was kind of a fun project
for sure and he was very interesting guy
to work with
and then that expanded more in the past
without my help to cover all the states
and include other things like Commerce
and ID systems authentication for
citizens to get to government services
it's probably quite a broad thing now
but originally it was really just a
fancy search engine for all the federal
content thanks cool well speaking of
history I didn't realize this and I feel
a little shame that I didn't you have a
long history with kubernetes in fact you
it you were there straight from the
beginning can you tell us a little about
your involvement there sure it started
as a small project with a few different
people Brendan burns job-aid crema
clucky and some people that are modern
lean especially with the now I think
people like Brian grant Tim Hawke and my
role was to help them form it into
something that made sense for Google
from a project and honestly to do
extensive internal sales to get Google
on board that kubernetes was a bet we
needed to take and that it needed to be
open source and both of those were
controversial the time and I'm so I'm
really curious as well like why back
then did you feel like this was such an
important project I mean obviously it
seems to have done okay now
but in retrospect I'd love to see your
perspective I think the reasoning was
sound and I think the track record
proves that but the reason he had a
couple parts the first part is that the
cloud especially then but even now is my
mind way too focused about the
infrastructure the machines the disks
and that is not the path to productivity
the path of productivity is are thinking
about services and api's and how you
build things that are highly available
and you don't want to worry about the
machines you really don't even want
another machines exist frankly it'd be
nice if we could just pretend they don't
exist at all and kubernetes is
absolutely a step in that direction so
that was part of it and I would say
that's my mission at Google is to get
the new cloud to be something that's
about services and API sand has nothing
to do with infrastructure it's there we
will manage it we'll make it secure but
as a developer you shouldn't need to
know the second aspect is that it needed
to be open-source because it's too big a
shift for Google to do by itself if
we're gonna change the definition of
cloud it has to be done broadly and
open-source is the best way to get that
done and I think there's a third aspect
which is if we make the playing field
about services and containers Google has
a relative advantage if the playing
field is about virtual machines we can
do that but we started very late in that
game whereas if you look at containers
that's something we've been doing for a
decade in Borak we have vastly more
experience on how to do that than anyone
else
we literally invented a bunch of the
pieces in Linux to make that possible
and understand them more deeply than
anyone else so we should be betting on
the places we can win this is a place we
can win you also we had mentioned to us
before we started that you gave the
first talk on kubernetes I gave the
launch talk at dr. Khan in 2014 we
released kubernetes that day I gave one
of the two keynote solomon hikes of
docker gave the other one where he
introduced swarm which for a while
competed with kubernetes but we had the
advantage that when we talked about
kubernetes it was already working to
some degree and people could play with
it and that really helped us get off to
a good start and frankly it's well
designed and it actually
works and so that was a big factor in it
being able to really take this space
nice and since then our ecosystem
especially at Google cloud of
open-source tooling has really grown
we've got astillero we've got open
sensors how do you see that that
ecosystem going forward I think it's a
core part of our strategy to be the open
cloud that was the talk I gave it next
in like 2016 there's 17 I can't remember
which one is 2017 but part of it is that
we want to make workloads more mobile
that is to our advantage if you use open
source things that can run on Prem in
other clouds and on Google because now
we're competing on operations on cost on
technology and that's the battle we want
them to compete in right so open source
inevitably allows a couple things that
are helpful us but the most important
one in my mind besides community is that
you can move workloads more easily to
GCP over time yes and I know you're
particularly interested in this do can
you explain where that fits into the
whole like strategy of where you're
seeing that workloads go sto has many
things I like about it but I think the
way to think about it is really it's
once you get a little bit bigger you
want to decouple the operations of your
clusters from the developers who are
developing new services and the reason
is tio does this is essentially that
it's intercepting essentially traffic on
its way into a service so that you can
automate the telemetry you get on every
service you can automate policies about
access control and DDoS and so kind of
all the control things you want to think
about for a service you put in the sto
layer and not in particular in the
source code right so we call this
externalizing I'm saying take all the
policy stuff that you currently have
hidden somewhere in the code of your
micro service take it out externalize it
so that we can manage those things from
ISTE oh and that has two big wins first
is it makes it consistent for all your
services because now you don't have to
update all your services every time you
want to change the policy which isn't
intractable but also as a developer it
turns out it makes you have more freedom
in the sense that
you don't have to negotiate with
operations what the policy should be you
worry about what your service does
operations worries about what the
policies are and we remove this friction
that's inherent if you have to on every
call site actually agree on what it is
you're doing right so we're taking out
coordination overhead which I don't
think people appreciate till they have
it but having been on both sides they
will appreciate it
in terms of the next cloud as you're
saying what are you excited about in
terms of what would be built off of that
once we get to a place we're able to
abstract more of the actual backend well
I actually feel like people using
kubernetes are already getting a lot of
this value now and that if you're
building an application out of a
collection of services and I made a good
example Spotify Spotify that was doing
this model before kubernetes existed
right they already kind of bought in do
we want to have api's and services and
they had built some me and how stuff
that was kubernetes like actually to
their credit but now we can give them a
much stronger platform to do what they
always wanted to do and when you add
this to you what that means is their
operations people can actually manage a
collection of services versus managing a
collection of nodes right so that even
the language they use to talk about what
it is they've built and how they're
managing has been up leveled to
something that saves them a lot of time
and toil there was a quote I'm gonna
actually read it to Kelsie Hightower I
think it was him that talking about
kubernetes is you you deal with the
application layer and not the
infrastructure layer does that sort of
resonate for you yes that is absolutely
when I say new cloud I really mean you
should worry only about the applications
and services that that you're trying to
build what are the biggest limitations
that we have that barriers to the new
cloud many things I would think first of
all there's a whole bunch of legacy
stuff that is really about you know
which OS version do I need and how big
my nodes have to be and how do I do
security patches those are problems that
you shouldn't have to have I would say
but there's a lot of legacy tooling
around how you manage the actual nodes
and OS images you're using right I would
like that to just disappear in some
sense and if you use DK it does
disappear because we manage the OS for
you we do the security patches for you
but there's still a lot of legacy stuff
that it works that way and tooling and
all kinds of things so that's part of
the challenge
I would say another challenge is even
kind of the core pieces like Linux
itself it kind of expects you to deal
with devices for networking right other
parts of the system like a file system
is kind of easy to abstract you can make
it look like part of a process model the
network and devices were generally still
very tied to the note so we're kind of
hindered by our legacy use of nodes in
various places but you know networking
and devices it's the one that stands out
most to me at the moment and that you
know is not easy to fix because changing
that requires changing a whole bunch of
open-source software that's using the
you know device level interfaces IP
tables things like that that are
inherently part of the node and we will
change those things over time what
that's not a quick process question that
comes to mind is um we talked a lot
about hybrid cloud at Google cloud
especially especially when talking about
things like kubernetes how do you see
that new cloud type of strategy or like
forward thinking working into hybrid
cloud type scenarios well we do see a
lot of people using kubernetes on-prem
already and that is because it's open
source it was very easy for people to
try it and play with it and use it
themselves so a side effect of that is
we've actually been building allies
inside companies who are using
kubernetes that will want to move those
workloads to cloud over time and I am
pretty sure they'll find that the best
place to move your kubernetes workload
will be GCP and gke is still
significantly better than any other
deployment of kubernetes and it's
managed for you and so if you just want
a focus on applications it's the best
manifestation of that vision so far it's
hybrid cloud I don't know if I want to
use this right term but I'll put it this
way um do you think hybrid cloud is a
almost stepping stone in the future of
cloud technologies like we have to go
through hybrid cloud to get to maybe a
full cloud or do you think that's
probably just going to continue to
evolve in terms of like you have to go
through hybrid cloud and I think it's
not a quick process moving to the cloud
for a large enterprise isn't not going
to be a single day event
right it's gonna be a ten-year event and
they'll move some workloads and later
other workloads and they will use
multiple clouds for honestly that's fine
so but what it means is if you want to
preferentially get future workloads to
move to your cloud you are better off
interacting with those workloads now
right so what I think about it is every
time there's a kubernetes cluster on
Prem and we can help it in variety of
ways that that has a net present value
to us of being a future customer load
that's it's more likely than average to
be on Google in the future we can
disproportionately win more than our
share of those workloads and I'm gonna
play a little bit of a role that mark
likes to play my podcast that I Drive
what exactly is hybrid cloud for those
who may not know the term it has a few
interpretations on part because
different vendors wanted to mean
different things so it's always gonna be
a little bit confused as a term but what
we mean by it is that you can have some
of your workloads on Prem some in our
cloud some in another cloud and they
start to feel like one thing and not
three things so an advantage to using
kubernetes and SDO is we can make these
three different environments feel much
more similar to each other and so for
example if you want to have a policy
about which users can access which
services you can enforce that policy on
our cloud on another cloud and
on-premise today
what makes it a hybrid cloud is the
consistency of policy that you can
expect to get over time now it does not
always mean I'm going to take a single
workload and split it across sites
sometimes that'll happen it's more
common that you're partitioning
workloads and some will run here and
some will run there and that to be in
the progress of migrating some of them
pretty much all the time for the next 10
years it says it's a it's a constant
state of evolving things in a stepwise
safe way the other advantage hybrid has
from my perspective is that there's a
variety reason that certain workloads
can't move to cloud today could be
regulatory it could be certain concerns
about
locality of data or latency or
you don't have a data center in the
right place for me or we have sunk costs
we need to use our data centers for five
more years all kinds of reasons and so
there's an appetite to modernize
applications on Prem using kubernetes
today versus waiting five years go to
cloud and then modernize right so part
of the hybrid strategy is to decouple
the movement of cloud from the
modernization of your apps you can now
do them in any order and we'll help you
and in fact when you have a portfolio
you'll do a mix of modernization and
movement and you can control that mix
however you like this modular as
possible yes you were talking before
about the value of open source do you
think that there's any specific things
that need to be done to help foster a
more comprehensive open source community
out there anything specific around the
open source space that you are very
passionate about her or find exciting
about where it's going it's a quite a
complicated space I would say we learn
despite having done open source for a
decade we're still learning exactly all
the best ways to interact with open
source but I will say kubernetes
particular has the strongest community
I've ever seen in terms of the rate of
Ciel's
the relative agreement on kind of
general direction and the extensibility
which means that a lot of arguments are
avoided because two different players
can do the same thing two different ways
and they're both compatible so the
structure of kubernetes both the
technical structure but off the
community structure has been very
effective and it's really a model I was
safe for other communities to try to
follow and it's different frankly than
other open-source efforts even within
Google so for example open source can
mean we release the source but we
control it that's kind of the Android
model it can mean we take pull requests
but we have to moderate them all that's
kind of the tensor flow model and so
still fairly Google centric but open to
submissions of improvements kubernetes
models much more open than that it's
really the community is actually
moderating the important changes and we
gave up the trademark meaning that the
foundation owns the trademark not Google
and the consequence of that which is
very intentional
is that we can't retract the use of the
trademark just because you're competing
with us or just because we don't like
the way you're doing it
right so as an enterprise it kind of
means that you know kubernetes and
you're right to use it is not revocable
at Google's whim nice on a slightly
different tract is there anything you're
excited to learn about in the next year
or two anything in particular that you
would love to explore especially if you
had the time for it sure I kind of feel
like I'm consistently behind on machine
learning and it's not that I don't know
quite a bit about machine learning I
actually do
it's another space that's moving very
quickly and I don't see how anyone could
keep up with both kubernetes and machine
learning and do it authentically so I
have some homework to do on that front
and I have some actual test projects I'd
like to do at some point but I'm not
getting to them so we'll see where that
goes see when that happens by the time
you probably get to them something will
have been built to be able to just
automate it for you or take care of it
for you at that point I can't say one
funny thing though which is that when I
learned about AI in school it's a kind
of a mess of a topic including expert
systems but one of the topics was neural
nets which then went out of favor for
quite a long time but it's one of the
part I know better than others because
it was still in favor when I was taught
the material pretty good now that
actually turned out not to be that
helpful because the field was advanced
so far that knowing the basics of it is
not as relevant as one might expect but
it's still still kind of useful
definitely so I'm wondering looking
forward and I'm guessing there's
obviously a lot of stuff you can't talk
about but are there particular areas
either open source or Google that you
think people should say keep an eye on
or or that you think are gonna rapidly
evolve in a really positive direction
well it's really the short-term ones are
there's a ton going on in the hybrid
space and particularly about how do you
create collections of clusters that span
different environments and that you can
actually manage as a single thing and
again that's something it has to be done
Google can lead it but it can't be done
by Google alone it's it's a big project
that fundamentally is going to involve
a lot of partners and we'll see a lot of
progress on that this year for sure so
we know Q Kong is coming up and this is
the big kubernetes conference can you
tell us a little bit about that in your
involvement this is a coop con Europe in
May particular and I've been to many
coop cons but I haven't been to one in
Europe yet so that'll be good and each
continent has its own kind of flavor of
coop con so it'll be good to see what's
different about this one and that is one
of the reasons I'm attending there's a
bunch of things I care about so
certainly the hybrid stuff I care about
it gave a talk at the last coop gun on
that and there's more coming on that
front but also just as I think there's a
ton interesting stuff on machine
learning and kubernetes aspects of
networking and management a lot more
users are now and production with
kubernetes so we'll hear some of their
stories especially in Europe that'll be
great but also honestly it's again hard
to keep up with this space and going to
coop con just forces me to spend three
days deep in it and make sure I'm caught
up again
let's see what's new and what's coming
what's what's been your most exciting
thing that you've seen somebody either
like extend or build upon kubernetes
that you can you feel like that's really
cool no that's a good question yeah I
think one thing I think is interesting
is people using clusters that are
disconnected from the rest of the
internet as a way to do a highly
available distributed system so you know
if you want to run something highly
available and you go write about network
connectivity having a local kubernetes
cluster turns out to be an excellent way
to do it and I've seen if I'm not sure
which customers I can talk about but you
can kind of guess that if you have a oil
platform or you have a retail store
that's in a remote location you might
want to have some local computing that
can keep your store online while your
even if your network is down that's
super cool and if we actually thought of
that that's very cool
definitely COO Bernays because it's made
to support high availability is a very
good fit for that so that sounds like a
really great customer use case for
someone who's using communities I know I
do a lot of stuff extending kubernetes I
think that the extension mechanisms are
really exciting have you seen any
particular extension mechanisms or the
extension of kubernetes as a as a
platform for distributed systems that
you
though it's been particularly inspiring
well assuming you mean CR DS as the
extension mechanism which is kind of
this API to have your own resources with
their own calls that is a fantastic
mechanism and it's really I think one of
the secrets to kubernetes success and
it's a subtle one because it's not
something you even si learn about the
first few times you play with kubernetes
but when you want to do something with
it that's not what it does it comes into
play and the real reason it's an
important part is again it means it's
much easier for different players to
make different changes and have them
feel kubernetes native and have them
work together so for those who don't
know CR de play customer resource
resource definition it's kind of like
you make your own little nouns and verbs
that extend the kubernetes model but if
you do it this way then all of the kind
of kubernetes tooling including the
command-line interface actually just
support your new extension and that
makes it very easy to integrate into
existing systems there any particular
examples of that that come to mind we're
using it for example the way we want to
manage multiple clusters is just an
extension of that that's important
because again you're gonna have clusters
on pram and in different clouds you'll
need to actually make sure that you can
manage them all I feel like anyone that
wants to do kind of a functions as a
service platform is gonna want to use
that kind of extension anyone that wants
to do a domain specific version of
kubernetes where you kind of narrow the
scope and say maybe it's for machine
learning or babies for I don't know for
retail that actually ends up being a way
you can do that but I think the main
thing about it is that because it
integrates with the tooling because you
can kind of have many of these things
Cole oded it's very flexible and avoids
a lot of conflict so in terms of your
career and the work that you've done who
have been some of the mentors or the
people that you've been inspired by as
you've been going down your path it's a
great question and there's always a
bunch and it's an you never quite know
who it's gonna be but let's see on the
technical side I would say three people
that stand out technically Butler
Lampson who is a now at Microsoft but a
famous computer scientist and Turing
Award winner who was on my PhD committee
at MIT Barbara Liske
who was my first advisor at MIT and
later won the Turing award and one of
the great women in computer science and
introduced a bunch of things that we
take for granted like abstraction the
idea that you might want to have a an
abstract notion of what something does
behind an API it's so obvious now but
someone had to do that right it doesn't
come from nothing and in fact I think
she got the Turing award a little later
than she should have because it was too
obvious which is a totally unfair
judgment right and this year's award
winner Dave Patterson who one of the
first faculty I worked with in detail at
Berkeley I got to Berkeley in 1994
worked on the now project which is about
to have its 20th anniversary because we
measure the anniversaries from the end
of the project that's the project that
led to cluster computing for the
internet and Inc to me and as in some
ways the reason I won the scientist
award for that train of work on cluster
computing and large-scale services and
so in that case it's not so much the
dave was the tactical influence although
great technically it's that he is a
great leader and showed how to do a
group project versus an individual
project so the now project had four
faculty involved I was in some sense the
fourth the junior guy and they were very
welcome to me and also just tell me a
lot about how is it you do research how
do you engage students how you get
things done and have impact and even
what your goal should be right the goal
should be impact and I've kind of
followed that advice forever agree any
resources that you'd recommend for
anything that you particularly find that
you're a fan of around the kubernetes
space around containers or on
distributed computing well you mentioned
Kelsey hi Tara so anything he says is
worth watching and I enjoy the time I
get with him and he's a nice compliment
to me in the sense that I have some
academic background he doesn't have
nothing he's not super sharp he is but
he has a tremendous sense of the
on-the-ground reality for kubernetes and
you can keep me honest when I'm being a
little too ivory tower ish yeah nice oh
it's a it's a great relationship for me
but also I feel like it's something
everyone could benefit from and you
often can make kubernetes which is
frankly overly complicated
talk about that if you like you can show
you the simple ways to get what you want
to do and that is a true art fortunately
we're heading up on the half hour
but before we wrap up is there anything
you haven't mentioned or anything you
want to make sure that it's on the
podcast that our listeners hear about
before we finish off there I guess I
would say that you should think about
all the toil that you have and the job
you might have as a developer and how
much of it we should be able to get rid
of over the next few years right because
part of the move to kubernetes is to
reduce the toil and the simple things we
can already do like we you're less aware
of your node and we can patch the OS for
you but we should be able to automate a
bunch of things like we're looking at
automating the testing process much more
and maybe we can tell you you know
you're running a bad version of OpenSSL
you might want to get rid of that right
that's something we can scan for and we
should be able to tell you and maybe if
you'll let us we can automatically patch
that too all right so there's a degree
of automation that's possible when you
get to this higher level abstraction
that's not possible if all you have is
the OS image and the nodes and that and
by the way that also enables a huge new
use of AI which is have the eye tell us
what changes you should make tier two
thing because we actually now have data
and we are talking at a higher love
abstraction which helps reasoning of all
kinds human and artificial excellent
angry that'll be a wonderful thing to be
able to have more automation to help
with that as well thank you again we
really appreciate you coming onto the
podcast and sharing all things
kubernetes containers distributed
systems and hearing about your mentors -
that was wonderful thank you my pleasure
thank you so much well Eric thank you
again for joining us on the podcast it
was wonderful to hear about open source
distributed systems
well actually what I think I enjoyed
most about that was hearing about his
mentor's yeah that was cool - yeah
anyways so mark if I want to visualize
the network traffic between my pods with
anna kubernetes cluster is there an easy
way to do this there is an easy way to
do this um I have I've actually tweeted
about this a lot this is a secret
presentation weapon that I have yes oh
don't tell anybody
yeah this is top-secret stuff here all
right
totally classified don't tell anyone not
my cell
be very very quiet about it there is a
great open source project from a company
called weave works where they have a
thing called weave scope and it's super
pretty if nothing else basically you can
install it on top of your kubernetes
cluster or they have a managed platform
as well but what it gives you which is
really nice is a really beautiful
topographical visualization of exactly
what's happening inside your cluster so
seeing pods and services and all that
kind of stuff but it also introspects
your network traffic so you can actually
see which systems are talking to which
systems which systems are talking to the
public internet that kind of cool stuff
and it just gives you a really great way
to visualize exactly what's happening
inside your system and whom is talking
to whom I like it when I can actually
see what's going on they show you some
visuals on that yeah so usually I use
that a lot when doing presentations
because it's really pretty and then it
gives you a really nice visualization of
what's going on and you can like zoom in
and out and it's pretty neat I'm
enjoying saying we works we've worked
all right well mark are you gonna be
anywhere in the next couple weeks I am
still not traveling very much but I am
actively streaming a lot which has been
lots of fun so you can find me on twitch
TV slash mark mandal I know you're
popping around and about so where do you
have to I will be speaking at the
Internet to Global Summit on May 9th in
San Diego and then I'm going to be
talking at the understand risk forum on
May 17th in Mexico City no that's where
you can find me I used to be here next
since we're talking about next I'm not
but are you I am speaking and so I'll be
speaking at next on organiz and talking
about how you can run game servers at
scale on top of open source software
fabulous awesome Melanie thank you so
much for joining me forget another week
thank you thank you all for listening
and we'll see you all next week
[Music]
[Music]